arnold schwarzenegger for president i'm  back the actor and former California  Governor admits he would have liked to  be able to run for president in the new  brand genius issue of adweek Arnold says  of the current election quote if I'd  been born in America I would have run  because now this was a very good time to  get in the race  unfortunately for Arnold he's not  eligible for the presidential race  because he was born in Austria but he  was eligible to serve as California's  governor from 2003 until 2011 despite  being a Republican Arnold has said he  will vote for anybody but Trump in this  year's election let's get down to  business  interestingly enough he's taking over  Trump's role on NBC's the new Celebrity  Apprentice debuting at January 2nd  you